Speaker 1: Now let's go to something that
is very, very good for Trump.
This is genuinely scary.
The Pennsylvania gubernatorial race also had
its primary yesterday.
Now on the Democratic side, running unopposed
is the state's attorney general, Josh SHAPIRO,
relatively unremarkable Democrat.
Smart from everything I've seen.
Likable, perfectly reasonable.
Uncontroversial guy.
Just normal guy would be a normal governor.
On the other side, on the Republican side,
the winner of the gubernatorial primary is
a guy named Doug Mastriano, who pretty easily
won with a 24 point margin over the second
place candidate Lou Barletta.
Doug Mastriano is an extraordinarily dangerous,
weaponized conspiracy theorist Trumpist, who
was in Washington, D.C. at the Capitol on
January 6th, who has promulgated so-called
Stop the steal conspiracies.
Who has played coy with Q and on phraseology.
And remember that the Governor appoints the
Secretary of State, the person in charge of
running Pennsylvania's elections.
This is really scary stuff.
Really, really scary stuff, too.
We have this interesting report about Mastriano
two days before the Capitol riots.
Mastriano said he was heading to Washington,
D.C. and calling out to God for divine revelation.
He used campaign funds to charter six busses
to shuttle followers to D.C. and told them
he would speak on the Capitol steps.
Around 1:00, rioters broke into the Capitol,
some wielding Bibles.
Jesus.
2020 signs an appeal to heaven, flags and
chauffeurs.
We'll get back to show favors on the Senate
floor.
One insurrection has called out from the dais,
Jesus Christ, we invoke your name.
And of course, you know the rest of of what
happened on January six.
So this is a wacky guy.
He was there for the stop the steal rally
ahead of the riots.
He tried to conduct one of these Arizona style
partizan reviews of the election results in
Pennsylvania.
He made debunked conspiracy theory claims
about the election a sort of centerpiece of
his campaign in Pennsylvania.
He was going to speak at a Q and on branded
con conference called Patriots Arise in June
of 21.
Ended up not doing it because of the chaos
in the media that was generated from the news
that he would be speaking there.
And the Republicans know it's really big that
Mastriano won.
Rudy, for example, was celebrating at posting.
I think this was untruth social.
Rudy Giuliani writing tonight, the biggest
win is Doug Mastriano in Pennsylvania.
He's a veteran and historian and a true patriot.
The most important quality in this election
is guts to destroy the Democrat Express train
to Marxism and the RINOs who enable it.
So the press will write nice things about
them.
Doug will be to Pennsylvania what Trump was
for the United States and he's not wrong.
They are putting the insurrectionists inside
the house.
Mastriano is disgusting.
Here's one wacky video back in January when
Mastriano announced he was running.
They opened the event with the blowing of
a shofar.
Now, I don't know how many of you know what
a shofar is.
A shofar is a ram's horn.
It's an element of the Jewish faith.
And it's used to signify sometimes the Sabbath,
sometimes the end of the fasting period at
Yom Kippur.
And there's actually a history of Mastriano
misusing Jewish symbols.
This was the start of the campaign for Mastriano.
Speaker 2: This people.
I believe God is about to manifest themselves,
although he has to, because we cannot keep
going the way we're going.
Amen.
Speaker 1: Dear God.
Okay.
So Mastriano is not Jewish and he has this
history of misusing Jewish symbols as campaign
props.
Back in April, he spoke and raised money at
a far right Christian conference called Patriots
Arise for God and Country, and they promoted
conspiracy theories, including the existence
of a global cabal of sex trafficking.
Democrats.
You guys have heard this stuff before.
911 was a false flag.
Vaccines are genocide therapy.
Adolf Hitler faked his death.
And once again, Jewish organizations criticized
that for the improper use of campaign props.
They also used a shofar there.
So this is a disgusting guy and he's a dangerous
guy.
The 2024 election could come down to Pennsylvania.
And if Doug Mastriano gets to decide who runs
that election, it's a really, really bad thing.
So Pennsylvania is becoming a major area of
focus.
We should support Josh SHAPIRO for governor.
We should support John Fetterman for senator.
Now, the good news is for now, that recently
Democrats tend to win the governorship in
Pennsylvania.
So if we look at some recent elections in
2018, the Democrat, Tom Wolfe, won easily
by 17 points.
In 2014, the Democrat Tom Wolfe won easily
by about nine points in 2010, a Republican
did win.
Tom Corbett won by about nine points.
But then in 2026, Ed Rendell ran away with
it with a 21 point win.
So the hope is that it's just an overwhelming
Democratic gubernatorial victory in Pennsylvania.
If not, we're really up for it.
And there's many different important races.
Months ago, we said Pennsylvania will be a
focus.
Pennsylvania's gubernatorial race is quite
literally a referendum on democracy.
This is as big as any other issue.
Just do you support a democratic system?
And if you do, you've got to vote for Josh
SHAPIRO.
And if people are looking to phone bank in
a particular race, that is a race that is
of significant interest.
Meanwhile, one bit of good gubernatorial news
from yesterday, far right Idaho gubernatorial
candidate Janice McEachin.
Oh, maybe it's pronounced Mcgeechan.
I don't know.
She lost in Idaho, and that is a very good
thing.
So initial results, a mixed bag.
Many more primaries coming next Tuesday, six
days from today.
And of course, we'll be covering all of it
live.
And just a quick reminder, Monday, Memorial
Day, we're doing a one day membership special.
We are blowing members.
We might run out of memberships.
Okay.
We are going to offer an incredible discount
off of memberships on our website, our primary
funding source on Monday, Memorial Day.
If you want to be notified of how to get the
discounted membership, just get on my newsletter
at David
Pakman
dot com.